foreign
[Music]
everybody I'm Josh Welsh president of
film independent and welcome to film
independent presents at the Wallace
yes we are so happy to be here tonight
and it's wonderful to see you all to be
back in person
celebrating uh the kickoff of award
season and more importantly than that
great Cinema before we get started I
just have a couple quick remarks um
first of all I want to thank our lead
sponsor the hfpa I want to thank our
evening sponsor Netflix and Above All I
Want to Thank The Wallace Annenberg
Center for the Performing Arts you guys
are a beautiful home and we love being
here so thank you and special thanks to
the Wallace's artistic director Paul
Cruz
um yes clap clap clap yeah
[Applause]
I just want to say uh we've been here
all week doing great programming here we
could not be more excited for tonight's
conversation between Maggie Gyllenhaal
and Stacy Wilson hunt you're really in
for a treat
um I at film independent Maggie
Gyllenhaal is an actor we have long
admired she was first nominated for a
spirit award back with secretary but so
many indelible and brave performances
since then I don't need to give you all
the list
but now with her directorial debut we
really could not be more excited and
honored to have her here as part of our
program tomorrow night we wrap out our
programming at the Wallace with not one
but two live reads
of classic screenplay so if you don't
know about these I'm quickly going to
tell you please get tickets and come
back tomorrow tomorrow afternoon we're
doing a live read of Sunset Boulevard
directed by Marley Matlin and we will
have a cast of both deaf and hearing
actors and ASL interpreters so it's
going to be a completely new I've never
seen a live read like this and whoever
comes I hope you all do is in for a
treat then tomorrow evening we are
wrapping out our our programming here at
the Wallace with a live read of LA Story
celebrating its 30th anniversary and it
will be directed by Marvin lemus the
creator of hentified and that will also
be a great night so come back tomorrow
please join me in welcoming Stacy Wilson
home
thank you very much hi everyone nice to
see you
Isn't it nice to be out and away from
your spouses and kids and the apartments
and homes that no longer feel fun and
welcoming yes
I'm so honored to be here tonight Maggie
is one of not only my favorite
performers and artists but just such an
incredible person and so kind and honest
and deserving of everything that she is
about to receive in terms of her career
which is wonderful
okay
[Applause]
we were both saying backstage that we
both get nervous for these things even
though we've each done them a million
times and I like to think it's because
we care a lot and we want you to have a
good time and we also just want to have
a good conversation so we decided to
just be loose and conversational yeah
it's also kind of a weird thing to do
it's a slightly weird thing to do and
also you're still you're still quite
young and so to be reflect
Ed very young so do not worry so we have
so much to get through tonight so I'd
love to just start and jump in right
away
to one of my favorite movies which at
the time I didn't really get and I still
don't but I love which is Donnie Darko
2001 directed by Richard Kelly the
writer and director and I'd love to toss
to a clip of a very memorable scene of
Maggie at the dinner table with someone
else you might recognize
[Music]
wow
maybe when you have children of your own
who need braces and
you can't afford them because half of
your husband's paycheck goes to the
federal government you will love regret
that my husband's paycheck oh
anyway I'm not going to squeeze one out
until I'm like 30. will you still be
working at The Yarn Barn because I hear
that's a really great place to raise
children that's really funny no I think
a year of partying is enough she'll be
going to Harvard next fall
um I haven't even got yet do you want to
say thank Michael Dukakis will provide
for this country till you're ready to
squeeze one out yeah I do
can I squeeze one out not until eighth
grade
it's me
Donnie you're such a dick
whoa Elizabeth
little hostile there
maybe you should be the one in therapy
then Mom and Dad can pay someone 200 an
hour to listen to all your thoughts so
we don't have to
okay you want to tell Mom and Dad why
stop taking your medication
you're such a fuck ass
please
you just call me a fuck ass Elizabeth
that's enough
fuck oh please tell me Elizabeth how
exactly does one suck a fuck you want me
to tell you please tell me we will not
have this at the dinner table stop
what's up fuck ass
so there's so much about this movie that
is Monumental the fact that it came out
around 9 11 which I know is very hard
for its success at the box office there
was some imagery in the film that I know
is troubling for the marketing
but it went on to have an incredible run
and still does as a cult classic so I'm
so glad it was made and I'm so glad it
still has um legs as they say and on the
occasion of the 20th anniversary or an
anniversary recently Jake your brother
told the guardian which I find that's so
fascinating he said Maggie and I were
going through a competitive phase at
that time she was the reason I got into
acting and was the more formidable of
the two of us yet I was the one who
started my career first so imagine being
in a movie with your obnoxious little
brother as the lead character
so firstly I'm wondering does this track
with your recollection of the way you
were interacting with him at the time
and was it therapeutic for you to be
able to say go suck a fuck on screen and
get paid to say that
um
yeah I guess
we were so young I mean we were
I don't know like I was like 21 Maybe
what I think looking at the scene is
that like I'd done a few things you know
like well like you know you're in high
school and you're an actress or you're
in college and you're doing things and
they mean everything to you and you're
able to express yourself somehow even
though they're you know just in high
school or college or whatever and then
your jobbing actress and you're trying
to get work and you you know like for me
I had you know ever I played the best
friend in 40 days and 40 nights or
um like I don't know whatever writing
cards with boys I had this tiny part
and there was no way to do what I
thought acting was which was kind of
like express myself like learn something
and so this movie too I just had a
little part but in that scene with Jake
you know and I don't think it's
particularly because we were competitive
or something I think it's because he's a
really good actor all of a sudden it was
alive like all of a sudden you know I
was like God how do you make it alive
when you have nothing you know right and
and that's continued to be a question
like sometimes you're like oh this scene
doesn't work at all how do you make it
alive but
because I was acting with Jake I
remember I was like oh
this is jamming you know did you feel
like I have to up my game a little bit
to sort of map twits with him
no I just felt like this is acting like
oh here we are this is acting this is
what I know acting to be and I I don't
think at that point
I mean I was doing closer and like
regional theater that's what I was doing
at the time in Berkeley I did it in LA
at the Mark Taper and that was a real
part and that was but on her film and I
I didn't have anything to work with I
didn't know how to make something alive
without it already kind of being great
at the time and so what I just feel like
I was like oh here we are here's
something to do you know and also
probably help Richard Kelly was 25 at
the time oh really so here's the guy who
told to me and he he definitely has an
old soul for sure I'm kidding because I
was 21. of course well four years older
of course but it may be helped that here
was a guy who was also learning
alongside of you and maybe he trusted
his obviously he casts the movie very
well and he thought okay these people
know what they're doing I'm gonna let
them do what I hired them to do
yeah he did you're right and that does
take like real
um that takes confidence for sure
absolutely so I'll never forget seeing
secretary at the Angelica in New York
and my roommate at the time who's a
filmmaker now
and I walked out on the street and I was
like oh my God what did I just watch and
it was so affecting and I was so proud
of whoever was able to get that on
screen it was so brave and we have to
give of course credit to Aaron kresida
Wilson who wrote the script and Stephen
Schoenberg who directed it
so I remember when the metoo movement
started there were some renewed interest
in this movie and I'm wondering now
almost 20 years later do you see it
differently and does it feel different
to you because it's almost harder to
watch that scene in our current climate
even though we know that they had a
connection and they actually had a love
for each other it's still it feels
harder to me than it did 20 years ago
how does it feel to you it doesn't feel
harder to me no I think
it's dangerous and it was dangerous then
and I'm really proud of that I think it
um
I think it asks a really really
complicated question I mean okay I was
looking at that scene and I was thinking
I've thought I've thought about
um
you know now that I am a director
um I think in some ways looking back on
my work as an actress I've often thought
about
um my work directorily
and if you look at that scene and
there's that
there's that scene of our that little
shot of our hands and and I put my
finger over James Spader's finger now
that is massively important to the
storytelling here because it was that in
the script no but it was happening every
time when we shot the whole scene and I
said to Steve Schoenberg you've got to
get this
and I was a baby but like he knew that
that it was that he is he's an
incredibly smart very very interesting
director but he didn't he didn't know
that that was happening he and I were
very much on the same page about what
the story was about so the story is like
it's like almost like an unsolvable
puzzle at this moment what do you do
with a character who is actually made
alive
empowered turned on
in every way
by this relationship with her boss it
doesn't fit into a black and white way
of looking at the world and I
I'm really proud of that and she's an
adult too this isn't you know she's not
a 16 year old and that becomes a little
bit dodgier and kind of more icky to
talk about she's an adult person yeah
right she's making these choices on her
own to engage in this yeah
right so like what do you do with that
right now politically I think I think it
is you know what's different is it's
much more dangerous now than it would I
mean I I don't know if there'd be space
for this movie now I don't know
and yet Netflix has shows that talk
about BDSM and this has become actually
an accepted form of a fringe lifestyle
that as long as people are consenting
and I think that's really the word that
we've all come to better understand is
consent is all of it so in this scene we
see two consenting adults well that's
why that shot is like it cannot be taken
out of that scene yeah I didn't realize
just just just sort of
um is the the argument against any
political problem in terms of whether or
not that you know that's what she wants
that is what she wants and that's what
this is dead person who's who's Made
Alive by this relationship what do you
do with that politically I mean like
it's it's dangerous territory we're over
the judge that healing process exactly
for someone else any more than any other
choice that people want to make about
their sexuality right or the way they
live their life or the way they love or
who they love definitely worth a
reviewing if people have I haven't seen
it in a long time but it's it's still
great and again gives us a lot a lot
more to think about now so the under
Sherry baby one again one of my other
favorite performances 2006 written
directed by Lori Collier and I know this
movie had a very small budget I read 2
million does that sound accurate I mean
I I thought it was like I think it was
1.3 okay you probably had to like wear
your own clothes and Source a lot of
your own props and stuff yeah so for
those who haven't seen the movie it is
just so spectacular but she has just
gotten out of prison she's trying to
reclaim her life trying to reclaim her
daughter and make herself living on the
straight and narrow which as we see is
not easy what kind of research did you
do into the nuances of that release
experience because I love we see her at
the parole office we see her meeting
with her sponsor it's a lot of sort of
banal sort of paperwork that people have
to go through which I really enjoyed
what did you learn about that process
oh my God it's funny when you say that I
can like hear myself in the Press junket
from like 2006 you know I don't really
remember I was not there so I'm not
taking what you said no but what kind of
research did I do I I did do research I
hung out with Lori Collier who was the
director and we went to I mean we went
to this prison on 20th Street and the
West Side Highway and and I don't think
it's a prison anymore a women's prison
we
um I I spend time at all these halfway
houses I
uh went to these parole places it meant
a lot of women it was really helpful
but then I remember Lori telling me that
she thought I should like sleep in my
bathtub
because I mean this is just now this is
just like um a difference in craft in a
way she was like I think you should
sleep in your bathtub to make you feel
really sore and uncomfortable really
tired and really sore like she was and I
was like Lori there is no way I'm going
to be able to play this part in this 1.3
million dollar budget where we shot like
six day weeks for like two minutes if I
sleep in my fucking bathtub like are you
kidding me like I gotta sleep in my bed
you know that's interesting so she
wanted you to even go even further than
you had already put in the work to do
right well no like yes the research was
really helpful and I do I think in some
ways like sometimes I think as an
actress I like being a little bit of a
bad student like I'll do some research
but so much of what's a pleasure is the
imagination is the fiction but in this
case I did a lot of research and she was
right because it was a world that I that
I really didn't know about you know and
to really give these women respect I had
to learn about them but I remember then
was like don't sleep in my bed and take
care of myself as best I can fair enough
and no one is judging you for not
sleeping in your bed
and then the final scene we see in that
package was from away we go 2009 written
by Dave Eggers and then de la Vida and
of course directed by Sam Mendes which
is a very different movie for him but
it's interesting you spoke earlier about
wanting that theater experience and I'm
wondering what did you get from him with
his being a theater person from a
director that maybe you hadn't gotten
until that point what was I saying about
the theater oh you were saying that you
were doing closer right so was he able
to kind of give you that theatrical
experience that you'd been wanting in
terms of his his style on said no away
we go was basically like I had a little
baby I think I was that your is there a
baby in that scene okay you can like see
his hand is just like this hard dog he's
trying to see this also my really good
friend who's playing my husband that was
Josh Hamilton right yes he's like my one
of my best girlfriend's husbands oh yeah
cute well he was very convincing as your
husband yeah but um so I think I was
doing Batman maybe or I don't know so
many people tired so a couple people
know me at some point Sam was like out
of the blue was like will you come do a
couple of days on this movie and or
maybe Peter was doing an education I had
been um in London doing one of those
things and um
and he said we come to a couple days and
so it was actually like really playful
it's definitely one of the most overtly
comedic roles I've seen I mean that is
absurd what we just saw I mean that's
very very I had I was like living in
Brooklyn with a baby and whatever this
was we you know like I was like kind of
sort of I mean obviously I'm making fun
of but I I that's what I was gonna ask
it was a satire a little little bit of
me
just a little did you use a stroller
when your children yeah controller okay
yeah you cannot live in New York and not
use this just a little you know it was
like it's like you're like only organic
food of course and then you get stuck on
an airplane in a you know snowstorm and
you're like just the kid needs potato
chips like it doesn't you know so I've
definitely like come down to earth a lot
since I had a
six month old or whatever it was
certainly and also with the second baby
I've heard that maybe things become a
little bit more relaxed after the first
yeah well when we talk about the last
daughter we can get into this I no
longer have such an idealized
perspective on any of it we're going to
do a deep dive into motherhood in a
little bit I think you know it's
interesting you were asking me before
um about what research I did for Sherry
baby
to scenes and I think it was around that
period of time that I really learned how
to work
like how I and and it makes me think of
my um of my acting teacher who died as
an old woman
um I don't know many years ago maybe
five
six even I don't know anyway
um uh
weirdly enough before I met her
she was working with Steve Schoenberg on
secretary so some of the incredible
notes I was getting from him I'm sure
were coming from Penny she then became
this like really powerful force in my
life and an incredible teacher but just
like any teacher just like anyone who's
offering you something like you have to
know how to receive it in order for it
to have any value really you have to be
ready too right yeah so of course
I'm so helped by her without even
knowing it and secretary she totally
helped me in in Sherry Baby I Remember
struggling with a scene
and she said oh I don't know maybe I
said one of us said
I just can't find my heart
and she mailed me a stone heart oh and
sweet and it if anyway whatever it's
still by my bedside table but these
scenes um I look at them and I think
okay that first scene that was one of
the first scenes we shot really yeah oh
wow and I and I remember afterwards Jeff
said and we were just getting to know
each other and we had to like in order
for that movie to work we had those
characters had to be in love it has to
be a tragic love story if you're not
rooting for them even though they're
totally wrong for each other and he's a
drunk and he's 30 years older than her
and it's you know then you have you
don't have a movie really
um and we knew that and so we knew we
had to create that love and so this was
one of the first scenes we did and and
he said afterward he said
that was like watching somebody be born
and but the thing is amazing that scene
is just this very simple scene but penny
my teacher
I didn't know if I told you her name's
Penny Penny Penny Allen she
opened it up for me like a geode and
same with that scene in them in the
honorable woman that scene doesn't read
on the page like that that but we
together
and again like in a way that is
directorial and there are some actors
that are just naturally directorial like
what I mean by that by the way okay I'll
just go like Veer off slightly I don't
know if you've seen I may destroy you
I haven't seen all of it I just started
it and then my husband and I were in two
different cities and we couldn't watch
it without each other because we started
it together yes we understand that but
um but so we
I think at least the first five or six
she didn't direct she wrote them I know
I noticed later she co-directed them but
I think she is an incredibly intelligent
actress and I think she's a directorial
actress for example there's a scene
where she has to take a morning after
pill and she plays the scene like she's
popping a Tic Tac and she's got her
potato chips and she's drinking her soda
and it's no big deal her friend calls
her what's up no big deal at all and
that reveals
totally how painful it is for her
whereas if she had played like 99.9
percent of the actresses probably like
myself the scene with just a little bit
of sadness or whatever you know you you
really lost me in terms of actually
feeling something for her so that's an
example of what I mean and Penny this
teacher taught me that she taught me my
point of view my need the reason I
wanted to do this movie The reason why
this movie of all the movies in the
universe came to me right now is there
something I have to learn and I have to
express
by doing it and otherwise what am I
doing who cares and that's
why and we can talk about this with the
last daughter too
you know
loving an actor or as an actor being
loved Scott Cooper
one time I was getting ready to do a
scene in the motel room with Jeff and it
was like one of the first real scenes it
was after this one but and it was going
okay it was a little tight and Scott
came over to me and said uh
Maggie
I love you
and that not creepy you know like you
know just he did
and
truly I think if you're loved
you can feel safe to go beyond what you
know about yourself
and learn something on screen instead of
pretending to learn something on screen
and I think especially in that honorable
woman scene that's happening you know
and and it's and and also Hugo Blick was
this director who
gave me such a Powerhouse yeah yeah
really directed basically edited
although I think someone else had an
editing credit produced
but um he gave me respect space
um
and love in his own way
this dude's a trip if you ever get a
chance but I love him too he's an
amazing autumn in terms of Crazy Heart
what's so interesting to me is
it's the first time you got what we call
the traditional sort of commercial
Acclaim in the form of an Academy Award
nomination and for me this is one of
your more commercial roles in the sense
that woman falls for guy and life is
disrupted Etc which is so not Maggie
Gyllenhaal to me like Maggie Gyllenhaal
does not fall in love with men and
change her career or get affected by
that kind of stuff so it's interesting
that the academy was like yes this is
the one for Maggie and not secretary
which I think is insanely audacious and
brave what you did did it feel like a
almost a reprieve to be able to play a
part like Gene to finally just be like
I'm just going to be a woman who's sort
of doing her best and just kind of give
in to that and Jeff being so wonderful
and supportive did it feel almost like a
vacation from some of that really sort
of grueling Indie work you had been
doing before that
you know I mean it was
as an indie movie you know very small
budget same kind of feeling right not
like Sherry baby that was crazy you at
least had two and a half million dollars
on this movie right yeah I mean it was
like it was it was it was like
functional but small movie but it got a
lot of awards pushed just ended up
winning like um
I think I didn't not think of it like
that I think she that character was like
she was like a heart she was like a
beating heart she was soft she was
she was like love you know she was yeah
not hard right she was a romantic
she like beyond that she's just a heart
hmm just like what sits next to your bed
right and for honorable woman this was
obviously your first foray into
television seriously like serialized TV
and something so dense and complex I was
saying earlier that I'm still processing
the show if you haven't had a chance to
watch it my God it's so it's I learned
so much about the world I just I was
very tested as a viewer
what did you learn about yourself making
that series that empowered you to take
more risks afterwards I I think I had
like a that was like I was 35 I turned
36 and I actually think everything in my
life changed around making that show not
because of like that show I grew up it's
funny I've heard my actresses my my you
know Dakota and Jesse have said things
like that about the Lost daughter that
they felt in some ways they grew up
I felt that way about the honorable
woman and I I really had um
well what makes me think of like
I had a 14 month old oh wow and I don't
know how old was Ramona seven
in London
I had learned something I went to make
Frank without Peter I took the girls
Gloria was six months old I had my nanny
with me but like everyone got sick and
was throwing up and like I I went to
Ireland to shoot it
two days before we were gonna start
shooting and I was like as I was walking
in the hallway trying to get Gloria to
go to sleep I was like never again if I
come to if I come to Europe I'm coming
two weeks early and I'm everyone's gonna
get settled and you know so anyway we
were in London we got kind of settled
and I I went to the first day of work
this is on honorable women now I'm an
honorable woman
and I like I kind of got after work I
kind of got panicked actually I think it
was maybe the third day of work I had
like an actual little panic I was like
how am I gonna manage this
I've made movies that are two hours long
this is eight hours eight hours and it's
incredibly demanding and an accent work
too I mean that's like a whole other
layer and that was like that was nothing
compared to all the stuff
I kind of liked that I kind of like wish
I had an English accent but you're very
good at it that was the Salve
um no but um I called a friend of mine
who you know who reminded me she was
like you have a 14 month old a
seven-year-old you're in a foreign
country you are taking on something
you've never done before she said it
makes total sense that you're scared
but
you just have to go to work like one day
at a time you know and and that really
that really helped me then I was like
right I don't have to make the whole
movie right now or the whole television
show right now I just have to make it
one piece at a time and I felt that for
whatever reason
learning how to work
um
my teacher also her husband died at
around that time and she really wanted
to work and so she and I sort of met at
this amazing place where
I wanted to work and she wanted to work
and and
the part for some reason just hit me at
a moment where I needed to learn
something and it took me kind of across
a little bridge where I I feel like I
became a woman
I love that yeah an honorable woman you
might say I really feel like the deuce
is one of HBO's kind of Underdog unsung
shows I remember when it was Aryan I
would tell people why are you guys about
watching this and it really is worth
revisiting or even just seeing for the
first time it's really great David Simon
and George pelicanos of course and you
played Eileen slash candy depending on
the scene and this show seemed the
perfect fit for you
based on the conversations that we've
had in the past about nudity and sex on
screen and in 2015 you told me the
following which I love you said quote
I've never been the hot girl
who was asked to take her clothes off on
the first day of work and if I've ever
done nudity there's always something
else that the scene was about
I want to see what a woman looks like
who's my age I'm much more turned on
when I see shows where bodies look like
bodies I recognize and I love that so
much because it's still so novel and I
love all the women in this show because
they embodied every look every size
every age every race and it really
brought a Humanity to sex work that I
still think is an ever-evolving
conversation
and your character
was based on a Loosely based on a woman
named Candida and she was a sex positive
feminist pornographer in the 70s
and I'm wondering in your research on
her and other women at the time who did
that work
how did your understanding about this
movement whether it be on the street or
on film how did it deepen your
understanding about this important work
that women have done since the beginning
of time women have had
no access uh to the you know economic
side of things I didn't have for many
many years and so in order to survive we
used everything we had in our toolbox I
mean in some ways Jane Austen
is an economic conversation I mean I'm
obviously not the first person to say
that it is you know and and the Val so
much of a woman's value is her sexuality
so
I guess
um
I can see that there's a difference
between actually having sex with
somebody for money and
knowing
that if you dress a certain way you you
know that the likelihood of you getting
a job is higher
but I think they're in the same
um
category and I'm not talking like you
know you wear super short skirt and
you're basically saying like maybe you
can fuck me I'm talking like just a good
bra
I'm just trying to be honest you know
and I think so some part of our value
because you know whatever it was we
couldn't have credit cards until 1970
whatever you know we couldn't vote until
a hundred years ago
included using our sexuality because why
wouldn't we we had so little it's not
like we all it's all we had really well
it's one of the things that we had you
know and so it's not like everyone was
like this is what how I'd love to do
things but if you're backed into a
corner and you know then I think you're
going to use whatever you can to get out
of it and so
um yeah that's what I think and and
that's what that's one of the things I
think about like how we all can relate
to sex work
um
I I also really think candy
was an artist and
um and you know probably is a nice way
to end up talking about the next thing
like I I I I candy was originally meant
to be a prostitute who was
um money-minded who was who became a
producer in the porn industry and became
a you know like kind of relatively
successful producer
um because she was a you know
a money-minded person and I just kept
saying to David
and George
she's got to be an artist she's got to
be an artist because if money is life or
death who the fuck are you if if art is
life or death for you and for someone
like this who has nothing and all of a
sudden she's made Alive by going to
shoot a porn and like going
oh my God whoa this thing I've been
doing over and over and over again for
the past 10 years if you put a frame
around it and light it
it's something completely different all
of this is light you know she's she's
her mind is woken up by that and then so
then so then it becomes life and death
for her so I was pushing like she's a
director she's a director she's got to
be a director here's why you know and I
would write these emails and I would
like I'm sure I was really irritated I
really love that by the way
one question for season one so she has a
son who's being raised by her parents
because clearly she's an unfit mom so
was that the driving force for her to go
straight and go legit so she could get
her son back no she doesn't go straight
right person honestly she's like she
didn't seem to too distracted it really
wasn't on my mind her son right I mean
like I know that was like so that would
be an easy crutch
she wanted to be a director and she had
no access to anything except porn so
she's like great let's film porn right
like she and and so then
in the same way I'm saying like I
learned something about myself doing The
Honorable woman but it was much more
kind of like unconscious and I was like
I'm a director I knew I was I just
didn't feel entitled
to even let myself think it and
and when I got to pretend and imagine
not pretend that's not the word imagine
fantasize think about it how would I
shoot the scene you know I was going to
ask was there a meta experience for you
plain candy of course yes I was like I
this is my job this is what I should be
doing you know when I I think getting to
sort of explore that by playing candy
made me brave enough to risk wanting
that myself and to think what those
women went through to be able to do
their jobs at that time was even you
know barely even a notion for people
there's actually a great scene that's
like almost all in The Cutting Room
floor in the deuce with dagmara Dominic
who is in um my film The Last daughter
she's so good oh she's so good and dag
and I play the scene where she is kind
of like a slasher director she did do
porn this character and then gets one
step up into like New York underground
slasher movies and I'm like how the hell
did you do it you know I mean there's
nothing open for them no you know
I love that it really is life in
imitating art imitating life I'm not
sure but something sort of meta and
circular it's all it's all like I look
at all these things I'm like that's me
that's me
it's all you yes because fiction
is gives you courage fiction gives you
bravery if you just do some if you just
try to like say this is who I am and
this what's is what's on my mind it's
way scarier than I'm protected by
fiction
but they're all me you know
well and the film for which we're here
tonight the Lost daughter
so I'm just curious how many people here
have seen the movie
okay good so I'm going to try for no
Major Spoilers because that is not nice
but we'll just try to talk about it in
kind of more theoretical terms because I
want one no that's good though I'm so
excited for you to see it too it's we
see so much in advance it's kind of like
that anticipation it's very special
so before we talk about the Lost
daughter I want to get back to something
we touched on earlier which is the
concept of motherhood and the theme of
motherhood which is so prevalent in your
work and I'd like to know what is your
relationship with motherhood both as a
child being raised by an artistic mother
an amazing mother and also your
experience with your children and you
give us a great anecdote about just how
hard it was to be a working artist
during those early years so how would
you describe your relationship with
parenting I guess in a general sense
it's a big big question I know
I don't think that's an answerable
question but I but I I I
I've been thinking
I think this might be a dangerous thing
to say I'm I'm curious
to try it out it's a safe space uh
[Music]
um
okay so I was thinking about Rebecca
Hall's film
I haven't not seen passing yet
um but I I know her and I know a lot
about it and as far as I understand her
mother was half black
and so Rebecca
a professional educated intelligent
woman who's not got her Apron Strings
tied to the stove whatever she gets to
make a film her first film and she makes
a film I mean not not exactly about her
mother based on the book but clearly it
seems like the waterfall of the domestic
and her relationship to her mother in
some way right I don't know I'm just I
was just thinking about this last night
while I was like well I was falling
asleep
in my film me too you know my my my
grandmother and my great aunt were
um a pediatrician and a lawyer in the
40s and 50s and my mother as you said is
a you know professional a thinker she
went to Barnard and she's a she's a
writer and a producer and um uh and me
too right I I also am a professional and
yet
when I am given the space to make a film
about whatever I want
um
it's in the realm of the domestic
and I
believe that women make movies that are
different than men I think they write
books that are different than men
and not everybody believes that I did
this really interesting interview with
Rachel Kushner who's a brilliant writer
I mean amazing and I said that to her
and she said I really don't agree with
you so fine I so so it's not it's not
like this is the truth but this is what
I believe I think when women are are
making films or or
whatever they're doing and they're
really listening to themselves they're
unconscious they're conscious their
intellectual mind their artistic mind
their erotic mind it's different and the
work looks different I was even just
thinking like I mean Lori Collier made
secretary made um Cherry baby but like
this movie looks so different you know
like different from from the ones before
right but it's true so I'm just
interested in some kind of tribal way
that I didn't even know I think in
the domestic and femininity
is is that I'm wondering is if that is
common to many women
I'm also interested in other things I'm
interested in a lot of other things but
my identity as a mother and as a
daughter and as a woman is like a
massive part of who I am
even though my film nobody's seen it but
you'll see like there's a lot of there's
a lot of ambivalence but there's a lot
of dissonance about that yeah if this is
not this is no fantasy version of
motherhood like but that's my experience
too you know
um
anyway I'm just sort of like starting to
think about this and what that means
that that for me if I get to talk about
whatever I want right now at 43.
it's it's got to do with my mother it's
got to do with my children it's got to
do with my relationship to those
relationships
the answer thank you
and so for those who don't know the the
film is based on Elena ferrante's book
and for those who don't know that's
actually a pseudonym we don't know the
author's real identity which for me
makes us that much more in compelling it
casts a paw of like a specter of of just
like even more I don't know it makes it
feel more foreboding does that make
sense it makes it kind of like hangs
heavier for me not knowing that this
person is out there but you're the
transmitter of this story which I think
is very brave of you actually and you
said recently of Elena you said that she
lives in my fantasy life which I thought
this is very cool she's this wise older
woman who gives me freedom and
confidence and she knew the only way for
this movie to be successful was it for
it to be mine and she wouldn't offer
this freedom to a man but she knew that
she had to offer it to me well she wrote
me that right she was amazing this piece
in the guardian as I was adapting okay
she did a couple of things yes she's
Anonymous I don't know who she is all my
interactions with her have been through
email first I wrote to her and I asked
her appealed to her for the rights and
you know I wrote a letter how did you
get her email I'm so fascinated by this
well my brilliant producers one of whom
is in the audience right now okay I
talked to her Publishers okay I don't
have her email sure so somebody's
communicating for her I have the email
of her there's one there's one couple a
husband and wife who own Europa editions
who are the sort of business liaison
between Ferrante and that's amazing so I
wrote to them and they got her the email
or yeah my letter and I I said you know
not what I was going to do because I
didn't know but why I wanted to do it
which I mean I can tell you if we have
time which was you know basically I read
her work I don't know how many of you
have read Ferrante probably many more
than have seen my phone so far but but
um but when I read her I had this
I had this feeling like
well first I thought
this character is so fucked up and then
within five seconds of thinking that I
thought oh no
I really relate to her
so and you said what does that say about
me right so am I so fucked up or in fact
are all of these things that she's
touching upon and writing about
a common experience that nobody's
talking about and that in fact so this
mixture of feeling disturbed and really
comforted
and I thought
What If instead of all of us because her
books really are flying off the shelves
instead of all of us having this this
sort of secret feeling alone in our
rooms
when these kind of agreed upon these
things we've agreed not to talk about
she breaks this agreement and says them
out loud instead of us having this kind
of electrifying feeling alone in our
rooms what if what if it was actually
said out loud what if I could put these
things on screen and create I mean the
amazing thing about a movie theater is
that it's both a personal
experience and a communal one
and you might be sitting next to your
mother or your husband or your sister
um hearing these things said out loud
and that seemed to me like a really
radical thing to try to do so I appealed
to her with that idea in a way and she
said and I said I wanted to direct it
and she said
um yes you can have the rights but the
contract is void unless you direct it
which was this kind of because she's
anonymous
she was just this like kind of cosmic
vote of confidence from out somewhere in
the universe feminine Cosmic vote of
confidence then she writes this uh this
letter in the guardian she writes a
bi-weekly piece in the guardian I mean
during doing my adaptation and I just
get this well I get all these emails
from my friends in the UK and my Israeli
producers being like read the guardian
and she she wrote this thing saying that
she thinks that it's as much as she
would like the movie to stay within the
parameters of her book
that she knows that for all women
that it's important that the movie be
good
and
that the only way that it will be good
really is if it's mine
and so she wants to offer me freedom and
she says if I was a man that she uh she
wouldn't offer me that freedom that it's
because I'm a woman and a woman artist
that she's offering it to me and in fact
um yeah you guys haven't seen the movie
but uh there's this brilliant actress in
it this Italian actress Alba roarwalker
and she's married to severio Costanza
who who is the man that adapted and
directed my brilliant friend for HBO and
so I've gotten to know him and he's
fantastic and he was like oh no it's
absolutely true he's like every day I
had an email in my inbox from Elena
Ferrante I was thinking what his
experience was now hearing this he said
they co-wrote he said he said in some
ways like it was like co-writing because
she was so involved so she means what
she says
and then and then just to finish her
you know that it's not that that she
lives in my well her anonymity has
allowed her to be a kind of a fantasy if
I knew she was with all her human flaws
and what you know
maybe maybe it wouldn't be as effective
but the in the end the the script and
the movie are very very different from
the book
um I absolutely think that they're in
conversation with the book but but
they're very different notably and I
won't give anything away
um the last line of the film is
basically the opposite of the book
I have a kind of endless respect for
Elena Ferrante not kind of I have
endless respect for Elena frante and I
really tried to understand the last line
of the book and I
kind of do now
but I decided to change it and um when
she read the script she said I see what
you did with the end and I love it
[Laughter]
Ah that's amazing you must have felt
much more put on her word this woman
foreign
[Music]